I'm...there have been an enormous number of
wonderful really revolutionary developments in these subjects of Geometry and symbology in three dimensions over the last
30 odd [years] and even an astonishing number of new things have been learned since the
Turn of the century [and] what I want to do tonight [may] be a little bit ambitious
But I'm hoping to take you on a whistle-stop tour
Through some of the ideas that have been involved so but in order to tell you about
What's happened in the last 15 years
Really I need to start by going back to the turn [of] the previous century
and
We need to look at some of the things that were going on then
To explain a little bit about geometry and topology as it was at that time and we'll see how that gets carried over
so the
Plan of my talk, we shall first see a little bit about what is hyperbolic geometry
That's the geometry that a lot of these developments are based on. What is this word topology?
Surfaces I'm sure everyone knows what a surface is
We will then move on into 3D, and then we get to the sort of late
1970s a complete revolution happens with the American mathematician
Bill Thurston, and so I want to give you at least try to give you some sense of the
Enormous strides that Thurston
introduced and
then
Since the Millennium there have been further
Enormous strides which in some sense have completed a large part of the programs that the stand
Initiated so I want to try and give a flavor of that, and then finally talk a little bit about an open problem
Which I think is very
fascinating and which touches on
The work that I've [been] doing and which also relate to some of the ideas
[I] shall be telling you, so that's where we're going to go
So hyperbolic geometry if you think about geometry at the end of the 19th [century] it was a lot of discussion
What is geometry?
[you] could say Geometries study of
Space well, we're going to start in two dimensions space in which wherever you are in whichever Direction
You look what you see is kind of the same, so whatever it is. It looks the same [everywhere] and
Of course the most obvious kind is ordinary euclidean geometry
But you might also be living on the surface of a sphere [and] wherever you are on the surface of a round sphere
Things look the same they don't look quite. The same as if you're on the flat
But they look the same and the third kind the [kind] that was
missing
Up to about 200 years ago is called hyperbolic geometry
So here's a picture that shows rather well
Euclidean geometry
Everybody knows the sum of Angles in a triangle is [180] degrees in a sphere
[well], what are the straight lines on a sphere? They're the great circles the way Aero planes would fly to go the
quickest way
so the great circles on the sphere
And if you start playing around drawing triangles on a sphere whose sides are great circles
You very quickly come to the conclusion [that] the Angles add [up] to something greater than 180
How much more than 180?
depends by a very precise way on the area of the triangle and
The third kind of Geometry then is the kind where?
The sum [of] the Angles in a triangle is less than 180 so there's a kind of pairing between these two things
so hyperbolic geometry you can think of as
Geometry on a surface which is everywhere
Saddle-shaped so you see in this picture it sort of curves down that way and then over a hump in the other direction
a surface of negative curvature
hyperbolic Geometry
was first discovered in the search for a proof of
Euclid's parallel postulate
but rather than finding a proof a whole new world of Geometry was discovered and
We can nowadays interpret it in this rather nice way
so
How are we going to model this geometry?
well
You can't put the whole
Sort of plane of this geometry
into Ordinary flat Euclidean space
because
It's too big basically, so this is one of a rather nice
series of crochet
Models that's been developed by [this] person [diana] tamina
There's in fact a whole book you can buy about making crochet models of geometry there's a whole project
Which has made a coral reef out of crochet which I think is in Dublin and not quite sure anyway
You can make these models and the main pointers once you [start] trying to make a surface that's curved the right way it
starts crinkling up and crinkling up
and if you kept on before too long
[you] would find it was just so crinkled around the edge that you just couldn't fit it in there anymore
And you would [just] have to stop because you you wouldn't have any more space to make your stitches basically
so
Here's another way to do it which perhaps
some people may be familiar with so if you know anything about the theory of special relativity
[you] [can] use the space which in which
special relativity takes place and
I'm talking about a
[two-dimensional] usually one has three dimensions of space [and] one of time
This we're just going [to] have two dimensions [X&Y] space and this is
time and this
picture over here on the left is a rather nice model made by a
colleague, so this is the show upon which Geometry takes place and
let me just go [on] and
It's not so easy to understand geometry there, so rather than doing that we project it
so just as you can think about Geometry on the surface of a sphere and
Projected onto the flat plane
So we can take geometry on this shape here with this rather curious formulas
And we can project it onto this circle
And this is the first time Poincaré's name comes up his name will come up repeatedly
through the talk
We projected onto this circle now. I didn't say but a
Shortest distance path on this thing turns out to be the intersection of a plane through the origin
with this
hyperboloid. This blue
Object and when you project it [down] what you see is
You see a disc here, and you see these lines, so these are shortest distance
Paths, Sort of Straight Lines in this geometry and what they look like in our map projection is
Arcs of Circles that hit the Boundary
that's right Angles and
So things are very distorted
But Angles are correct, so that's good
There is a of course there are precise formulas for all this which I'm not going to try to explain tonight there are formulas
and
The main thing to remember that this is like a very distorted thing like when you projects onto a flat atlas
Things are completely distorted up near the north pole. They're very wrong so don't think that this is a correct picture
but nevertheless let's carry on and
Talk about tilings a lot of what I want to say is connected with tilings
So everybody knows how to make tiling patterns in the ordinary Euclidean plane
Kind of thing you
play around with it's cool and
You can make tilings of the sphere
this is another nice model made by Henry Segerman, so here is a sphere with a
tiling [Pattern] on it, and he's rather nicely projected it in this photo onto the flat plane and
Of course here, you can see here's a sphere
Well here's everything distorted so we kind of see the idea of distortion in a projection
what about tiling the hyperbolic plane there is [a] picture of a tiling of the
Hyperbolic plane and the thing to take in here is that although these shapes. They're actually hexagons
Although they look different
actually from the Viewpoints of this geometry they're really the same so in other words just as in the
[hexagons] picture every tile is identical to every [other] one
There's a rigid motion of geometry that carries one to the other the same thing is true in this picture
[one] thing about this picture is that
If you count the number of tiles around here they increase
Linearly as the radius of your circle if you count the number of tiles here you find they increase
Exponentially fast and that's related to this croche surface that I had that was all crumpled up
There's more and more and more of them, and there's an infinite number of them to get from here to here
It's an infinite distance and this rather
Wonderful Little video clip shows you probably better
It's going very fast, but there we [are] all of these shapes are the same and we're zooming on
Peter Leaper is another computer graphics person who's got kind of fascinated by some of the things that can be done in Mathematics
So this is a picture and as you see we go on and on and on forever
And out at the Horizon it just goes [on] [and] on and it's infinitely far away
So that's my very quick introduction to hyperbolic geometry we're going to come back to this geometry
repeatedly
Let's go on to what the word topology means
So [Topology], what is it?
[it's] the study of things that remain invariant
unchanged when you do deformations here is a
picture of
What do I mean by a continuous deformation will I take a thing and I squish it and I scrunch it
and I pull it, but I don't rip or tear it and
I want to ask. What remains the same well if you like
The fact that there's a little hole [that] I could sort of go through here between her [buck] and her front
It's still here [even] though things are a bit kind of distorted well, there's more the same in these pictures
But you could distort much more than that. So that's what's topology is about and
Well again, the name of Poincaré comes in so let me introduce Poincaré. I'm sure many people here
well acquainted with Poincare a he was really one of the absolutely great mathematicians of all time [man] smart Mathematician and
Mathematical Physics he
contributed to
enormous numbers of different areas and in particular
He's often known [as] the father of this subject of Topology although
He wasn't quite the first person to do it, but he was really the [first] person he made
Introduced an enormous number of ideas that are still the fundamental tools of this subject
He also of course was the person who
wrote down the Lorentz transformations in their modern form which are used in the theory of relativity special relativity
He was the person who probably can be credited with the invention
In some sense with the invention of what we now know as Chaos theory so many many things and I rather like this
quotation which I'll leave you to read
Felix Klein was one of the leading
German Mathematicians at the sort of later part of the 19th century
Klein actually drove himself and to have a breakdown trying to compete with Poincaré, and eventually [I] think gave up and
realised and
Wrote a lot about Poincaré this rather wonderful tribute
so this is Poincaré as I say his name is going to keep continually cropping up throughout the
so what about
Surfaces then what can we say about
surfaces from this Viewpoint of
Topology and perhaps by the time I've said it you will have a bit more feeling
So the idea is we take it easier to see a picture. [here's] [a] surface
now if you
Take a loop a closed loop on this surface that just kind of goes round it once here
And you cut it of course, it'll come apart and what will [it] look like in Topology?
Well, it would be like a cylinder, but a cylinder is really the same thing if I took a sphere and I cut two
discs out of the cylinder
And then I squashed it so from the Viewpoint of Topology if I make [one] cut through this thing I get a sphere
with two holes and
if I took this one
And I cut each one of the two handle things with a cut and I opened it out
I would find I had a sphere with four holes, and if I did it on this one
I would have a sphere with I think six holes
so
Here's another one you might think this one is different because it's all twisted up
It's still like this, but it's all twisted up
but it's only twisted up from the Viewpoint of [how] it's been put inside three dimensional space and
that the
Classification that we're talking about doesn't see how it's sitting in three dimensional space
Still if you made one cut it would still fall apart into this sort of cylinder with two ends, so it's still a torus
So the way we classify
surfaces
Here's a rather beautiful. [I]
Think this is a bronze cast it's not very large
I [think] the real thing Carlos [sequin] is another of these kind of computer people
With a very artistic bent who makes rather wonderful
representations of
Topological
Objects, so it's much harder to see this has got to you can see it's got some
Holes cut in it, but it's harder to understand. It's got
It's genus [2] but let's believe that's what it is
so that surfaces
And it took I've told you this in lesson in a couple of minutes it took a long time to sort all this out
So this is not meant to be
Obvious depends what you think of surfaces to start with?
Anyway, that surfaces now. We're going to now go [into]
Geometry on surfaces
What can we say about Geometry on surfaces?
So this is one of the very important ideas in [this] talk and one of the important ideas in
the I could say really in the modern study of Topology, what's the
Geometric structure, so
supposing [that] I've got some objects and
supposing that
In a little region around where I'm standing I can manage in some way to measure distance and Angles in
Such a way that it looks identical with a bit of one of these
basic Geometries, I've talked about so it might look a bit like
this flat euclidean geometry it might look [like] a little piece of sphere, or it might look like a little piece of
hyperbolic Geometry
So [a] sphere well everywhere I stand on is fear, and I look around me
I see a little piece of a sphere, so that's not very exciting
What about a torus so I'm sure that you've seen
Pictures like this you take a rectangle of paper
You glue two sides together to make our cylinder. Here's our cylinder.
You pull the two things round you stick them together and Lo and behold. You've got a torus
I'll tell you where this picture came from
later
[okay], so we can make a torus actually there's a sort of cheat in this because of course [I] can roll up and make a
cylinder if I try and to do this part
actually if I try and do this in 3D
Naively
Plainly the things going to all crinkle and crunch all up
It's not going to work very so there is a bit of cheating here
But it's not really cheating because what I'm talking about is what you would see [if] you were [a] fly
This is a kind of abstract concept if you like if you were a fly living here
Well actually or if you even with a fly and you walked across this line
It would be no different [from] going across here, and then coming back in here
So somehow there is a meaning [to] seeing this thing is basically
coming from a rectangle cut out of
[Euclidian] geometry
so
The torus has got euclidean structure. So here's a picture
I take my square, but then if I went across this side
I kind of unfold it and see another copy of the square and another copy and another copy
Really I translate it, but let's not get too detailed here, so you can so here is another picture
Here's another picture of gluing up this torus
And there's one very crucial feature in doing this that it was very important that
when I glued well first of all when I glued from here to here [that] this plus that
Were to 90 degrees so they made 180 degrees so they met at a straight line, and then when I put the two ends together
I've got to lots of 180 degrees and
That's um
Those add up to 360 and that makes a nice smooth flat piece
it makes 360 degrees and that's
fine, so there is
What we mean by saying a torus has a euclidean structure, so I've somehow to this surface
attached a natural notion of
Euclidean geometry
Well, what happens
if
I now go to a surface which has got two holes
genus 2
So here is [a] picture if you follow through this if you would to glue the opposite sides of this thing together
You can go home and puzzle about this for a long time
But it is true. [I] assure you that if you glue the opposite sides together you're going to have to kind of come round yourself
Maybe go through [yourself] depending
How you do it?
But you should in the end be able to convince yourself that if you glue it up you come out with a thing like this
Okay, so let us believe that but the trouble is if you took an ordinary octagon
then eight of these corners have got to meet up here and
whatever the angle in an octagon is I think it's 135 degrees if anyway if you glue aided them together
There's no way it makes 360 degrees. It's way way more. It's too much
So you glue [em] together and the angle is much too big so you haven't got a nice?
Euclidean structure because if you try and cut it out of a piece [of] paper and glue it up
At the last minute you'll have a nasty mess in the middle where it doesn't fit together flats
So what are you going to do about it? Well you remember
That in hyperbolic geometry the angles in a triangle
Don't have to add [up], or don't add up to 180 they add [up] [to] something less [than] 180
and actually you can create triangles whose angles add [up] [to] anything you like less than
180 and here is a really beautiful tiling of the hyperbolic plane in which we've got a nice regular octagon and
the Angles here have been
manufactured each to be 45 degrees
so when I stick eight of them together
Lo and Behold I make 360 degrees
so it's nice and
locally
making the right angle that it should do and so I've created a surface if I could cut this piece of paper out of
hyperbolic paper which has got this kind of curvature, and if I could stick them together
I would have created the surface of genus 2
and
Actually by just adjusting the angle using this trick. You can make a surface of
any higher genus you like and
this was I suppose known and understood it was being studied a lot in the
1920s and you might say well, so what [actually] [it] became very important because
Anything you want to study about this surface you want to know what closed loops are on it
Somehow if you look at this pattern [that's] rather complicated
But beautiful pattern you can read off all sorts of things here and one thing you can do is you can study particles?
Sliding around on this surface, and it turns out that by studying the intricacies of this pattern
and by realising that things
Geodesics in this in this hyperbolic plane they come close together, and then they kind of diverge from each other
and that's the essence of chaotic motion, so
sliding around on one of these surfaces is a
Prototype for what we now call chaotic motion and this was one of the first examples. That was really studied and
introduced the idea of
Randomness and chaotic motion but by a perfectly well-defined formula
So this was in the sort of [1920s] and probably 1930s for that
So let me just recap very fast we have learned that we know how to classify
Surfaces and every surface in a natural way has got a geometry on it
It's either like a sphere or it's like a piece of Euclidean plane
but in usually
it's like the hyperbolic plane right so now we are set to proceed [into] three dimensions, so
[my] first problem in this is there is not a normal English language word for the 3D analog of a surface
Nobody's yet. Come up with a very good word
So a thing that's an analogue of a surface, but in more dimensions is known to mathematicians as a manifold
So we took court talked about a 3-manifolds, [so] what it means is everywhere. You look in a little bit
it looks like some sort of very squatchy vague version of
three-dimensional space
But it's got all sorts of complicated loops and tubes and holes and goodness knows what's in it. So some very complicated thing
Well, we just seen how to make a surface by
gluing up the sides of a hyperbolic octagon
So supposing we took a hyperbolic polyhedron
and
supposing we glued up the faces [if]
We were lucky we could fix the angles
So it would all work and they'd fit round
They'd have to fit around the edges nicely and they'd have to fit right at the corners, but if we were clever
we might be able to do it and
We might be able to produce one of these [3-dimensional]
objects
which just in the same way that we glued up in 2D and created a
Surface of some genus we can create
something in 3D which we can say has a hyperbolic structure and
It comes from this process and now we come to some really
Amazing pictures just as in 2D we could tile we could kind of unfold the thing the torus
into a square tiling
so in 3D
we can start with for example this which is the same as the one on the previous slide and
we can unfold it into a tiling of
three dimensional space, so
[I] don't quite know how to make a drawing like this like it's amazing, but anyway, so here we are
we've got that the walls of this thing have [been] made transparent so you can see and
you're sort of seeing through to the cells [if] you like so imagine you could imagine a sort of
A
[cubical] tiling of ordinary Euclidean space this is an [analogue] in Hyperbolic space and Jos
Leys... Jos Leys by the way has a rather nice website with all sorts of pictures in particular. There's a whole section of
Rather Wonderful tilings of Hyperbolic 3-space
Okay, so hyperbolic geometry in 3D. Well it produces some pretty pictures, okay?
Right okay?
Before I can go and I have to give you an alternative
Viewpoints
if you go back to my original picture about
hyperbolic Geometry
sitting inside the spectrum in Minkowski space of special relativity if
You look out to infinity along the light cone. You see it sort of in 2D. You see a circle in 3D
You'd see a sphere of stuff. That's way out at infinity and
I
Also, said we can model
Two-dimensional hyperbolic [spaces] the inside of a disc so not surprisingly you can put 3D hyperbolic space
inside a sphere
So far so good
So here is a picture another picture by Jos Leys this tiling that we saw
you could stand sort of on the outside of the universe and look in and
You would see something rather wonderful like this
Point [quarry] I guess when he was working with these lorentz transformations and special relativity
realised that
the
Isometries is word
I haven't used...Isometry means a rigid motion a congruence things like that are like congruence is in Euclidean Geometry
So Isometry means keeping the distances the same
so
We have something a rigid motion inside
Hyperbolic space that's moving tiles to other tiles
But actually it does something to this sphere at infinity and on this sphere at infinity
You [can] calculate the formula now. It's a formula [on] a sphere
but
No doubt some of you
know how you can think of the sphere you can project it from the top onto the plane and
You can think of the plane in terms of complex numbers?
x plus iy
and so if you take the plane together with one points
points at infinity
[you've] made a sphere, so you can kind of transits really like stereographic projection nothing more than that
So you can translate the formulas into some simple formulas?
with complex numbers and
we can write down the effects of an isometry of
[three] [dimensional] Hyperbolic space inside the ball we can write down the effects out on the boundary and
This formula at the beauty of this formula is it's just a two by two Matrix or a nice formula like that
And we can just multiply two by two matrices and do all [our] calculations
So instead of having to have some quite complicated 3D stuff. We can work in 2D and
Hope yeah there we go
Now we can see what what I'm doing? Now is I'm showing [you] the effects of a
particular isometry of three dimensional Hyperbolic space
But I'm just looking out at infinity and watching what it does out at infinity
So this man is getting transported around
And that's why we're watching him waiting for him. Here's the formula
so I just wants you to remember this for later on [and] so everybody will remember this a plus d is an important quantity and
Why is it important well you can see that [this]?
Person is going around in spirals, and he goes forward into a kind of sink, and he goes backwards into a sink
So there are there's a forward sink and a backward sink and in 3D. What's this isometry doing?
there is a hyperbolic geodesic going from a line going from
one end to the other end, so it's a sort of piece of circle or [Saag] and also my boundaries fear and
This transformation is pushing along this axis and twisting as it goes so it pushes along
And the twisting is you see that effect in [the] spiraling?
So that's what one of these
mappings does so it's very important when
[you] look out at infinity all the facts about being rigid motions
go away, but still a lot of good stuff remains and
just think about this kind of motion along an axis that you translate on you rotates and
That can be read off from this this a plus d number called the trace
okay, so
Now I need to introduce another
idea that was one
Isometry supposing I had two or several isometries
And supposing I do a bit of one and a bit of another [and] a bit of another and a bit of another I keep
Going with them, and I allowed them to go backwards as well, and I pick up the picture of this poor man
And I transport him around this particular one has just got he's got one thing
That's pushing him one way and another thing pushing him another way, and he gets twiddle around and what happens
Instead of the being just two fixed points a source and a sink
There are actually a whole
continuum of
sources [and] [sing] well a whole countable number of sources and sinks and he get you to see his images get smaller and smaller and
smaller but they go all the way around the edge of this thing and this thing is called the limit set of this collection of
Matrices and
You can also think of it as the chaotic set when you get to that level
Everything's moving around chaotically in fact you don't quite see it in this picture
But there's boundary here is a very complicated and rather beautiful fractal curve
Now I'm not really going to go into this
too much this evening, but
We explore. I wrote a book some years ago with
these other people and
David Mumford is a very brilliant mathematician David wright was originally a student at Harvard
[he's] also a number theorist, but he's extremely good at
Computing we wrote a book [explaining]
How you make pictures like this?
And in particular a number of people have taken that up in particular. Jos Lays used some of our recipes, and that's how he
Created some of his pictures
so let me now start I can now start telling you some more recent Mathematics and
The first thing I'm going to tell you is about
Hyperbolic manifolds, whose volume is finite?
right well, I take a finite sort of
original Tile or cell
finite size, and I glow up the side so what I get is a finite size, so that's what we're talking about and
we assume that this thing is glued up, so there's no boundary anywhere and
Now there's something about 2D. I didn't tell you if I make for [example] a torus by gluing up a
rectangle I can make it a long thin rectangle or a short fat rectangle and
I can actually skew it into a parallelogram and still glue up the sides
So I can do a lot of things and it will still be euclidean, but the tiling of the plane will change
And it turns out in 2D, you can always do that. There's a whole science called tight molar theory about
how you can deform
Geometric structures on surfaces in [3D] a
Theorem
Famous Theorem called the Mostow Rigidity Theorem says in 3D. You can't do that things have fixed. They're rigid
so what does this thing say supposing I've got two of these finite volume manifolds and
supposing
Well for the mathematicians supposing
They're fundamental groups or abstractly isomorphic
But imagine not all of you were mathematicians so supposing
they're topologically the same somehow you know that you can squish one and do all kinds of mess to it forget the Geometry altogether and
You can get to the other one
Actually, then they're really the same thing there isometric. So rigidly you pick one up, and it's exactly the same I see
So that's what Masters theorem says
And now I'm going to talk about something else. So that was a tile
Which was finite volume I've been more concerned with tiles which have got infinite volume
So here's a picture in 2D
So this particular yellow tile you can see it goes all the way out to infinity, and there's a kind of
Thickish piece that goes out and that means it's got infinite
size, and
here's another picture now this picture is a
What you see [at] infinity?
from a 3D tile so imagine I've got my
Hyperbolic space inside the ball, and I'm kind of looking through from the outside in and there's some complicated basic tile
And it hits the boundary at infinity
And then you can take all the copies of it and so I tile the stuff at infinity
So [that's] what you're seeing in that picture, and you can see how the tiles get smaller and smaller and of course
what do they do they pile up on this same thing the limit set of the group and
If you would take this stuff out at infinity you
[could] play the game [of] gluing up the sides of the tile
but now
We're distorting things by these mobius maps
That have forgotten how to measure distance, but they do know how to measure angles
So you can think that whatever it is. I mean by Riemann surface. It's a kind of structure
That's like geometry that only remembers angles and there was a great deal of work in the 50s and 60s
Studying these things and here's another note famous theorem. It's a bit like him
an [analogue] of the Moscow Theorem, it says
that if I stick up these things
then if I control what happens out it in so it's so
There's a tile and in the middle of hyperbolic space that what we glue up the sides of the tile
And we produce a solid thing that has some bit that goes off out to infinity
An out at infinity, we have this floppy tile
that's glued up which only remembers angles and what Berbs theorem says is if I know what happens to the
Angles that there's stuff out at infinity, and I know that for every part of the tile that went out to infinity
Then I know everything then it's fixed so it's sort of like an analogue of [Mostow's] theorem
so hyperbolic manifolds we can think of finite volume we can think of ones with tiles going out to infinity and
Then there's a rather subtle distinction that probably kind of lost
at the moment, but anyway you can have
Finitely many sides or infinitely many sides of the tile, so what do we know well
there's a tile with an infinite number of sides and
We're sitting inside a tile. It actually only takes two
Transformations you wouldn't quite believe it
But because of spiraling that you don't really see it actually only takes two isometries to glue up all of this stuff and [make]
some complicated manifolds
So what was known well
We knew this wonderful monster rigidity theory, but we didn't really have many examples
there was some there were some nice examples, but they were sort of a bit special and
Almost like curiosities. Maybe some examples to do with number theory then we had the theory
Bers Theorem and
There's a picture of Bers who was I
think he was originally finished, but he spent the
Latter part of his life in the United States originally he worked on fluids, but he got drawn into [this] subject
So well okay there was this that was pretty much not many examples, but we understood something
something was understood here these were a complete mystery except Bers and
The work of a few other people said there must be some funny things which don't fall into this category
So there is some that we don't really know anything about still
so that's where we were at and then William Thurston came along, so
[in] the sort of late seventies and early eighties
Thurston started he came into this subject, and he started proving just incredible theorems
Remembering in 2D we knew
That every surface had a certain kind of geometry attached to it either
Euclidean hyperbolic or spherical
so the first thing that Thurston began doing
Was he started taking
lots of three dimensional manifolds that the topologist kind of Understood
but only in terms of Topology
they didn't know anything about they didn't have anything to do with Geometry he just took these sort of abstract constructs of
Topological
Objects, and he showed that actually you could impose all the in a natural way [a] hyperbolic structure you could make this
Basic Crystal that you could glue up, and you could make it hyperbolic
So I don't have time to tell you what it's very technical what classes of Manifolds, but
Really very large classes, and this was completely astonishing nobody had
imagined anything like this before one of the classes was if you
Take 3D space, and you draw some complicated [knotted] loop and then you drill that out of space and throw it away
And take everything that's left
That's the manifold, and he showed that most of those are actually hyperbolic manifolds in a very
precisely defined sense
so
He then went even further and he made something known as the geometrization conjecture [that]
He might ask is it possible then that there's a way of putting Geometry on every three dimensional manifold
We could do it in 2D well
you
Nobody before him conceived anything like this
But he conjectured that in view of all the things he'd already done
and he'd shown were hyperbolic that actually not that there was a
Particular Geometry on every Manifold, but that after you
So just as if I take a curve on a surface and cut it before it opens out if I for example draw a torus
Inside a manifold and cut along that
I'll get two bits of manifold the bit that's on one side and the bit on the other and
maybe the bits on one side and the bit on the other side separately have some geometry so that's
what he showed, and he also showed there were only eight types of geometry and
They're all quite simple and in particular. [we've] got spherical, Euclidean, and hyperbolic and
Actually, so he conjectured this was true. I
Didn't prove it to just give you a sense of how
Sort of what an immense conjecture this was I'm sure many people have heard about the Poincaré conjecture which I will
come on to
Let me not say what the Poincaré conjecture is right now people may have heard of it
But the Poincaré conjecture was a problem that throughout the 20th century was basically driving Mathematicians nuts
and
Says he not to me is not only that he proved these
Wonderful theorems, but he introduced all sorts of wonderful
Concepts he was a very visual hands-on
Mathematician Sadly he died quite young and we're not young, but I mean he was not old you see a couple of years ago
But he was always tremendously keen on getting
students and schoolchildren a [saw] and doing things by hand and making shapes and playing with shapes and so on So he
He left an enormous legacy of of ideas and he had so let me
Show my next slide
so by the time
Thurston Had
Been working with [a] large group of students who were attracted to work with him
what has happened in Finite volume closed Manifolds well an
Enormous amount from being a few [isolated] examples with a good theorem muster rigidity
It became a huge big subject huge big area
Large large large classes of Manifolds are actually
hyperbolic and
A great deal of effort went into writing up sort of nice versions of his proofs and so on
here's a picture of this and more reason there was a big conference on his 60th birthday and
All of these students of his have them in themselves and of themselves made large contributions to Mathematics
so this case well let me just say it was recast from A
Subject that was mainly about mobius maps out of infinity
into something to do with Topology and Geometry and 3D and
This rather mysterious thing that must exist well
Thurston did not
Solve the problem, but he began to tell us what to do
So what has happened since the year?
well
these two conjectures
[which] I only had told you what the poincare conjecture is but the poincare conjecture and this
Geometrization conjecture, which is much bigger and includes the poincare conjecture
Then there are three things whose names
Won't mean anything, but three other very important things which Thurston and some of his school put together
that between them if you understood this you would have understood this mysterious exotic case and
People really didn't know how to do this stuff
Maybe they had a little bit of idea about how to do this as I'll show you but really
Beyond that there was a lot of
unknown stuff and
What have we done used to show you mathematicians been quite busy?
so famously
With an enormous amount of press coverage Grigori Perelman
Proved the poincare conjecture [right] that I mean depends when you think a theorem was proved that from the time the person first
Announces the proof to the time when it gets checked and possibly published can be really quite long in mathematics
So dates are a little bit
so Perelman proved this Poincaré conjecture whatever that says and then
based on these methods
this
Perelman went further and he explained her to use his ideas which were completely coming from a completely different direction to
[prove] geometrization he left a little some gaps that have been filled in
Then these three things [all] of these were large
Pieces of work, so we've kind of done it all you know everything
Right [so] let me tell you in a little bit more detail. What's the Poincaré conjecture?
the Poincaré conjecture in 2D if I draw a loop on a sphere I
can shrink it down to a point.
So I could ask the opposite question if I had a surface such at any time. I drew a loop on [it]
I could shrink it down to a point on the surface
Would it be a sphere and that's part of how you classify?
surfaces so it's true that if I gave you a surface and
Every loop that. You could draw around the surface
So here's a torus [I] can draw a loop so [this] orange thing rounds here
And no matter how I move it around and stretch and twist, [I] will never get rid [of] it
I can't shrink it down to nothing
So I can detect if I was a fly I could detect whether I was on a sphere or on the torus
By looking at these loops and could I shrink them [down] or not?
So an innocuous sounding thing supposing I went up to 3D
Three dimensional thing if I was in a three dimensional sphere I could do the same thing could shrink everything to a point
What happens the other way [around] if I could shrink everything would it be a sphere?
Well you might think that wouldn't be so hard
But actually it's incredibly hard. I'm really incredibly hard and all sorts of people tried and
There were many
Sort of incorrect proofs that were announced and then people worked hard and found the mistake in them and this went on and on
Another slightly strange thing in mathematics you might not be able to do something in three dimensions
So let's try and go to higher dimensions. Maybe it's easier
And it's kind [of] easier because there's more space
So it's kind of it's [harder] to think about it. We don't think about it
[you] can just move things so you can kind of move things out [of] the way and move them around each other and so
It could be proved in
Dimensions greater than or equals five and then it was proved in Dimension 4 and it was still sitting there
unsolved in Dimension 3 and
Some big prizes the claimed Millennium prizes were set up
Just before the year 2000 of some outstanding
Problems of mathematics there was going to be a million-dollar prize for the solution of any of these
the Poincaré conjecture was one of them and
Well just about the time Grigori Perelman you see here
Proved it and he used. I'm not an expert on this at all, but his methods were completely different
He started with not a homogeneous kind of metric at all, but a way of measuring distance
That was just sort of anything and as a clever way of kind of smoothing it out. Smoothing it out
smoothing it out and you come to
Sort of singularities, and you have to get round and cleverly but eventually you proved that this thing that you
Didn't know was a sphere has to be a sphere
and then he went on in outlines how to prove geometrization and
using similar methods and as I say the word there was some some gaps, but they've been for
Okay, and then we have the other three conjectures which is more the direction
I've been involved in so here's a picture one of the things this and did he didn't have time to write up his stuff
nicely just throwing out ideas [everyday], but there is a
huge
volume known as Thurston's notes which with lectures he gave and
were typed up and
the sort of beginning part has now been
Very beautifully [edited] and filled in and produces a book the latter part is still sitting there
You can find it online of course here's a picture about
So we've got this manifold with infinite volume and the thing is
What he said, it looks like you don't really don't know what happens as [it] goes off to [infinity]
but what he said it might look like is this you might have [a]
Surface and then just take copies of the surface all the way going up and create a three-dimensional object
So just like you can take a circle
And then a line and make a cylinder you can take a surface of some kind
genus 2 in this picture and go up
And you make a 3D thing and the key point really was that as you go out along here in
These weird examples these exotic examples there would be
Geodesic loops that wouldn't be getting very long all the way out along this thing forever and ever so the on the face of it
this
End of this manifold is infinite volume bit
We couldn't understand might have done anything it might have been twisted in all kinds of terrible Wild ways
but actually he sort of tamed it and
This timeless conjecture says that well maybe it always looks like this so Thurston showed in certain cases
it looks like this and then Thurston also showed that
Well, how would you recognise which type it was?
It turns out these curves that go sort of lie on these surfaces these geodesic loops that go out and out and out
They you can sort of think of them like rational numbers
And they have a limit which is some kind of irrational number an object thirst and introduced called a geodesic
Lamination and
what he conjectured was if
you knew what the
Irrational numbers as it were connected to each of these ends were then you'd know everything well that seems pretty remarkable
But actually turns out. That's true
Not only is it true
If you know what happens on the ends here actually you can more or less
Reconstruct everything that happens in the middle and this was not thirst and this was largely yair, Minsky
working with various other people introducing some really beautiful mathematics and
understanding the kind of course Geometry of the whole
Hyperbolic manifold [just] from a very small [amount] [of] Data about [the] ends
And then finally well could there be any of these things kind of sitting out there?
We don't know where they are
Well the answer is no they couldn't
They'd always have to be limits the ones that we knew about and it turned out that once
We kind of got this far. This bit was
Fairly Routine and quite routine, but it was more obvious to see how to go about proving that so that was also proved
right well now I don't know if I have time, but let me try to go very quickly through so
You I'd say we've solved all the problems. So we one thing I didn't say was
These [three-dimensional] things you can put geometry on them. We know a great [deal] now about the geometry examples
It actually turns out that if you in many senses pick a manifold at random. It's going to be hyperbolic
Just as most surfaces are hyperbolic
so in three dimensions by far the most common thing to happen is for your
manifold to be hyperbolic, so hyperbolic has gone from being a kind of
slight
Sideshow to something really fundamental, and I would say we're at a point now. Where we kind of understand
But I said that surfaces were used for example to develop things to do with Chaos theory
People are playing now, but I think the facts
We now know about these [three-dimensional] things are surely going to come into play [in] the future in ways that we haven't as yet
Understood
ok so
well very fast okay, so
discreteness so discrete means
That you can move things away
Frigid motions of some tiling you can move the tile away from itself and it never comes back and hits itself
On the other hand if you start [rotating] thing and you go rounds an irrational angle
an angle that's that's not commensurable with [2PI] then you can go round and
You'll come back, but you won't come [back] exactly on top of yourself
And you'll keep going round and round and [round] and you'll end up producing a picture like this and the longer you go the more
It's the [more] you'll overlap yourself
So being discrete is kind of nice
let me just skip here and
Then let me just show you my last slide, so I don't have time to tell you that but let me just leave you with
this last picture, so
Just a picture of what it looks like to fly around in
three dimensional
hyperbolic space [this] picture was made by
this Geometry center which was part of the offshoots of all the flurry of activity round cisterns work, so
I'll leave you that thank you [very] much
What would a galaxy your solar system look like in the universe with hyperbolic geometry?